habe ich gerade schon ganzes Intro ohne
Ton gedreht habe ich die mikrosituation
sieht bei mir nie so richtig gut aus
meine scheiß Haare im Weg jetzt mit
Leben ne eigentlich habe ich zwei Zöpfe
ist ja nicht so dass ich diese Frisur eh
schon sehr komisch fand vielleicht ma
ich auch einfach die Haare hoch was ist
das jetzt für eine Frisur I hate it
immer wenn ich vom Spiegel mir eine
Frisur überlege dann gucke ich mich
danach in der Kamera an und denk so oh
mein Gott wie siehst du denn aus ich
habe mich heute in ganz pink angezogen
das hat ein ganz
bestell gr und zwar packen wir heute den
Kes Adventskalender aus und das meine
Damen und Herren ist ein riesenil im
Vergleich also zu mir ne ich bin ein
Mensch mittelgroßer Mensch der ist
schwer der ist groß und vor allem habt
ihr den so oft nachgefragt ich hatte den
noch nie in Betracht gezogen deutsche
Sprache schwer was will du bist du
kaputt in dein Kopf aber warum nicht wie
schmeckt so schmeckteg K ist
mittlerweile für mich Top 1 bei
Fruchtgummis so mit hitchis zusammen
Haribos waren es früher aber ich finde
die vegane Auswahl ist hier viel größer
natürlich also katja ist ja absoluter
Vorreiter gewesen wie Vegetarier sollen
den Tieren das Essen wegessen und ich
hätte aber jetzt nicht also ich habe
irgendwie nie daran gedacht den wirklich
mal ernsthaft auszutesten aber
vielleicht ist er was besonderes drin
4490 kostet der und damit kann man schon
sagen das ist einer der günstigeren ne
im Adventskalender Game sind wir ja
mittlerweile bei normal so 100 80 €
sogar 140 € und da muss man sagen mit
44,90 € hat man sich einen sehr
günstigen Adventskalender geholt das ist
quasi das Äquivalent zu dem 1 € Aldi
schokoladenadventskalender von früher
unter
4490 excuse me wir haben 2023 ja ey und
ich sag's ehrlich ich hatte vor 2
Stunden 3 Stunden Mittagessen und habe
jetzt Bock auf ein kleinen SNO so kurz
vorm Abendessen und warum nicht einfach
24 mal Süßigkeiten sich reinpfeifen das
ist halt mal wieder dieser Tage wo ich
meinen Job extrem Liebe wir fangen an
mit tüchen Nummer ein und bevor ich es
vergessen dieses Video ist nicht
gesponsert und jetzt alle dieses Video
ist nicht gesponsert aber Kat Hit mir ab
ich werde euer Kaas Girl falls ihr K
Girl braucht W lustig wenn ich mal
irgendwann einfach nicht bei Nummer ein
Anfang wir fangen an mit Türchen Nummer
1 ich glaube es passiert einfach das was
ich vermutet habe Nummer ein werden da
jetzt einfach
Fullsize Gummiprodukte drin sein
cherries cherryes Mix cherryes Mix wer
ist Cherry
cheros
Cherry der sheros Mix denn Frauen die
Heroes sind sind shero die sehen aus wie
die Fledermäuse von Haribo sind das
Frauen mit männertypischen Berufen oder
also hier haben wir eine Frau mit einem
wie heißt das mit so einem mit so einem
Werkzeug cooler
Shiro be auch ein Shiro lecker ich will
wirklich aufpassen nicht so doll zu
schmzen aber es tut mir leid falls es
mal passiert Rock ja lecker sind diese
festeren Gummis 99 Cent kosten die
sheros bestellt ihr sowas wie Kates auch
online das ist für mich so ein absolutes
Supermarktprodukt Nummer 2 das hat jetzt
alles aber auch gar nicht so ein
weihnachtliches Thema ne das ist ja
einfach ich also das Video ist einfach
ich probiere Katjes Süßigkeiten das sind
einfach Fullsize Cates Produkte und
wahrscheinlich habe ich hier am Ende das
Cates Regal zu Hause stehen Wunderland
Rainbow Edition alles so in Einhorn so
wenn das jetzt auch 99 Cent kostet dann
wissen wir wo das hingeht ne die
Wunderland Edition gibt es in sauer
Party Wunderland Wunderland Rainbow und
die Pink Edition ja 1 € ihr habt die
leise Vermutung dass ich einfach 24 1 €
Produkte hier drin hab die 24 € wert
sind aber dafür 44,90 € bezahlt habe ich
meine dafür sind sie in einem pinken
schönen Karton
aber ja ich probiere jetzt nicht jede
oder also weil wenn ihr die seht dann
wisst Ihr doch auch wie die schmecken
Nummer
D man muss schon sehr großer Kat Fan
sein und wirklich jedes Kates Produkt
mögen katzenfoten ich ma jetzt 99 Cent
ich glaube nicht dass das irgendwie
anders kosten wird Nummer 4 schon Taus
mal
gegessen aber immer noch super die
Freddy Ferkel also damit hat meine Liebe
zu Kes begonnen dieses Video ist
wirklich nicht gesponsert bitte glaubt
mir Klassiker Klassiker auf dem Schulhof
machen einfach weiter ich bin mal
gespannt das habt Ihr mir eingebraucht
salzige Heringe ich finde die nicht
grundsätzlich eklig oder schlecht aber
dafür muss ich so richtig in der Mut
sein und ich weiß nicht was das für eine
mut ist aber das muss richtig man muss
so richtig Bock drauf haben jetzt ist
gerade nicht der Zeitpunkt ich habe
schon so ein Berg katesüten hier so
Nikolaus was bekommen wir denn an
Nikolaus bei diesem weihnachtlichen
Adventskalender ich kann es kaum
erwarten
okay also ich bin jetzt gerade wirklich
überrascht 100% Alpaka Wolle made in
Nepal i love
it W mein Kanal schon länger verfolgt
weiß dass ich ein kleiner Alpaca Fan bin
und das als
Schlüsselanhänger ich meine wie kann man
es nicht lieben ne seid ehrlich es es
ist riesig aber es a alpackerwolle und
es ist aus Nepal ich find's gut das ist
nikolausüchen für mich meine Stimmung
hat sich gedreht ich bin jetzt gespannt
sie das Party Wunderland y Tropenfrüchte
die kenne ich tatsächlich noch nicht
frag mich jetzt ob die schmecken wie die
tropicals von Haribo was soll das bitte
für eine Tropenfrucht sein das ist keine
Frucht das ist also steht da was drauf e
exotic vielleicht ah ja exotic ach da
stehen einfach nur die Worte drauf was
es für ein Geschmack ist und dann nicht
mehr so ganz deutlich
Kiwi krass der Geschmack ist jetzt nicht
so wow aber die Konsistenz ist für vegan
echt gut wenn man aus Bioladen so vegane
Gummibärchen holen möchte dann ja ist es
irgendwie immer nicht so überzeugend so
Türchen Nummer ne Kates die kennen mich
wir haben was Gutes eingepackt nein
grünohrbeeren ich muss bei diesen
grünohrhen und jetzt auch bei
grünohrbeeren ich muss da immer an
Keinohrhasen denken an diesen Film mit
Hill Schweiger SMS sind auch
verboten Keinohrhasen dafür dass der
grüne ohrhase total cute und cool ist
ist das ein bisschen vom look
so
was sage ich super lecker aber das Ohr
ist nicht grün die sind ein bisschen
fester aber die kann die noch nicht
deswegen wollte ich sie auch mal
probieren Nummer ze ein absoluter
Klassiker aus dem Supermarktregal die
Glücksgefühle von Kates also eine Sache
hat Haribo find ich ein bisschen besser
als Kates ich habe das Gefühl Kates
verkauft das gleiche Fruchtgummi einfach
nur in verschiedene Form und nicht mal
krass anderen Geschmack für mein
erachten bei Haribo hat man bisschen
mehr so oh das sind lange Schnüre und
sind picoballa mit irgendwas gefüllt und
das ist so und also jedes ist irgendwie
so ganz neu erfunden wenn ihr wisst was
ich meine Nummer 11 oh mein
Gott oh mein Gott ich Flip aus Katies
vegan Schokolade Rainbow Crunch ach so
das stimmt das ist deren Schokolade
warum auch immer die wollen bestimmt den
vegan süßigkeitenmarkt erobern da steckt
viel Geld drin like money ein toller
Look für diese Schokolade und die
Streusel geben ein total buntes schönes
leichtes Gefühl und da probieren wir no
jetzt mal glatt mal ein Stück vegane
Schokolade ist sehr
schwer positiv ist ist mal was anderes
mit diesen Streusel da drin dass du SAS
knackig crunchiges hast und vom Look ist
sie sehr sehr schön aber ich hätte gerne
mehr so dieses weiße Schokolade
Geschmack aber ich kann ja auch keine
weiße Schokolade me Essen kriege ich
blhungen was kostest du denn 1,79 € ich
finde aber die hätte bisschen früher
kommen können ich hör auf mich zu
beschweren Nummer
12 wow ihr könnt es nicht glauben also
wenn ich euch das jetzt zeige dann seid
ihr so okay seid ihr bereit für das
Gefühl Gute Zeiten schlechte Zeit boah
das ist so crazy das ist für mich so
90er das ist so für mich meine Kindheit
meine Eltern haben das oder meine
Schwestern mit meiner Mama hat das immer
geguckt Gute Zeiten schlechte Zeiten
durch Liebe und Schmerz wirden gut
schlechten Zeiten dein
Schicksal Schum sehr lecker wie ionic
ist das denn bitte ich Flip aus ist Zeit
für die andere Seite ich weiß nicht ob
es die Nostalgie ist aber gute Zahlen
schlechte Zeiten
13 wow Fred in Party
Fred was gibt denn
nicht aufpassen den hundeleckerles
Martin Rütter Hundis können wir nicht so
eine Youtube Edition kriegen es rie nach
Schokolade nach
Lakritze ja gut K ihr habt mich
[Musik]
damit die sind ja richtig cool der
duckel I can't ze von Geschmack lecker
mag dieses leicht schokoladige
lakritzige
martinrüter ich glaub nicht das jetzt
dieser von Kat dass sie so völlig
verrückte Sorten machen 15 oh das ist
eine ganz normale langweilige Sorte die
kennen wir doch schon Wunderland in pink
16 geschmacklich absolute Favoriten die
sind auch tiptop so wie die Pandas
schmecken bisschen die Mar Martin Rütter
Hunde lecky schmecky Nummer 17 ich komme
mit diesem Adventskalender so in
weihnachtsstimmungachs strange love
strawberry chocolate ma ich jetzt mal
nicht auf ich kann mir ungefähr
vorstellen wie sie schmeckt die packe
ich lieber in die verlosungsbox kann
sich jemand drüber freuen in der Nummer
18 befindet sich UI noch mal Wunderland
sauer die hatte ich noch nie probiert
die Wunderland sauer ein gelbes Herz für
euch weil ich euch so lieb hab da geht
noch ein bisschen mehr sauer meint es
gibt eine Weihnachtsedition als am 24
ich hoffe es ja ne katje ist Kinder oh
mein Gott ist das die original katches
waren das mal Lakritz Cat Katze katches
Katze isut was heiß K Kätzchen geragt
gejagt superin s aber ganz hart ich habe
keinen Bock auf Lakritz das wird mir
gerade nicht schmecken da sind sie die
grünohasen
21 cool frisch jung K Pop die Ken ich
nicht auf Popart angelehnte Gummibärchen
guck mal wie cool die sind wow wow
lecker sollte nicht immer zwei Essen
eins reicht fühlt sich an wie so einne
tasting nur mit Kates das ist ein
schmackatz
was wir da drin sein K feel good hier
seht ihr das Gummibärchen was genau
diese Frau hier symbolisiert
23 Happy New Year sweet XM peace love
das ist doch mal eine Christmas Edition
hier kannst du Namen drauf schreiben und
es dann jemanden zu Weihnachten schenken
ich finde Kes ist das beste
Weihnachtsgeschenk was man kriegen kann
das ist doch einfach nur die peace
Edition oder warum steht den da XM das
sind alles nur friedenssymbole also klar
wünscht man sich an Weihnachten Frieden
also ist keine Weihnachtsedition auf
gwei das ist die love peace Edition mit
ein bisschen XM Thema drauf gedruckt so
die 24 das letzte Türchen es ist
Weihnachten du hast dich in den letzten
24 Tagen nur von Kates ernährt deine
Eltern haben vielleicht schon mit dir
das Gespräch gesucht gefragt ob du nicht
vielleicht mal was anderes essen
möchtest du hast gesagt nein ich liebe
Katjes das heißt Kätzchen und ich liebe
auch Katzen jetzt machst du das 24
Türchen auf gibt's noch ein Lama ich
meine
Alpaka oh Gott ich dachte schon es ist
ein Beutel es ist ein Beutel es ist ein
Beutel mit Reisverschluss ist green
Circle gut das ist sehr gut hergestellt
muss man sich manchmal fragen ne 100%
recyced okay ja gut das ist kein
weihnachtsadventskalender also auch vom
Design ich meine hier ist ein cutes Lama
was über den Kopf hängt oder ein Alpaka
das hat nichts mit Weihnachten zu tun
aber muss es ja auch nicht also ich bin
z.B persönlich jemand ich brauche das
ich das muss Weihnachten schreien aber
für jemanden der vielleicht auch ein
Kalender haben möchte und aber nicht so
ein Weihnachts Freak ist für den ist das
ja auch völlig in Ordnung ich muss jetzt
einmal nachzählen wir haben 20 cties
Packungen 20 € und dann noch zweimal die
Schokolade 1,79 € dann sind wir bei
23,58 € plus das hier
das heißt man bezahlt dafür 21
€. weiß ich nicht muss das ich meine der
ist cool der ist aber also sehr einfach
also das ist jetzt hier nichts
kompliziertes ja das würde ich jetzt z.B
für irgendwas zum Aufbewahren benutzen
aber ich wer jetzt glaube ich ist schon
cute aber ich wer jetzt nicht damit
obsess so oh das ist mein neuer Beutel
ich liebe meinen neuen Beutel mit
Reisverschluss das Ding ist finde ich
sehr sehr süß das Ding ist das kommt ja
halt aus Nepal deswegen ist das nicht so
ein Produkt was jetzt hier in China für
20 Cent produziert wurde das ist
wahrscheinlich ist das vielleicht sogar
sowas wie Handarbeit oder so also ich
glaube wenn du oder einer deiner Freunde
ein riesen Kates Fan ist dann ist das
ein super Adventskalender weil dann hast
du ins Schwarze getroffen wobei man ja
auch sagen muss man mag ja bestimmt
nicht alle Sorten man hat dann aber alle
Sorten also man könnte halt auch einfach
die Lieblingssorten kaufen und dann 24
Türchen reinpacken und dann bezahlst du
24 € aber dafür kriegst du halt das
nicht das hat halt mein Herz erobert we
Einpacker ist der ist schon der ist
schon sehr süß trotzdem es
ist shy andererseits kostet es natürlich
auch so ein Ding zu verpacken ich habe
aber schon irgendwie gedacht dass Kat
ist da so ein oben drauf packt aber
bestimmt kostet dieses Ding alleine 15 €
davon gehen wir jetzt mal aus es geht
hier aber am Ende auch ein bisschen um
meine Meinung und ich sage nö also ich
würde jetzt dir nicht krass empfehlen
ich finde den aber tierisch süß
ja das war's ich hoffe euch hat's
gefallen bis zum nächsten Mal tschüssi
und nächstes Mal will ich irgendwas mit
mehr Weihnachtsstimmung haben